this is Aquarius the world's only
operating undersea laboratory scientists
can live down here for up to two weeks
giving them as much time underwater as a
year's worth of regular diving living
down here day and night means getting to
know the reef intimately I'm marks rope
and I'm heading out from Key Largo in
Florida to dive to the lab I could be
one of the last visitors because with
budget struggles ahead the US National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
which owns the lab is recommending that
Congress cut its funding I'm going to
meet the researchers who think Aquarius
is worth saving here I go the lab is 17
meters below the surface and it's been
in operation here since 1992 there it is
inside I'm going to meet marine
scientist Mark Patterson who's been
working out of Aquarius for years an
ocean advocate Sylvia early in 1970
Sylvia was one of the first scientists
to live underwater Sylvia can you tell
us a little bit about what your first
undersea lab experience was like yes
was the most striking thing
we're and shirt Gibson or now juries
there's a qualitative as well as
quantitative
become a resident not a visitor
you get to see the same pressure get to
know their faces
and I don't mean oh there's a bangle
shop
there's that angelfish that he's always
there they usually that level of
intimacy means researchers here can
notice things about the reef they might
otherwise miss because they are living
underwater they can spend ten or 12
hours diving a day without worrying
about decompression sickness over the
years they've studied how sponges filter
water how ocean acidification is
affecting reefs and why reefs are in
such poor shape it's gonna sound kinda
nerdy but actually recognize the
individual colonies out there because
I've done physiological experiments on
that individual in the past and I know
okay well this one's adapted to light
and this way and responds
physiologically of water motion in this
way I got funded by National Science
Foundation just recently to test a model
of how corals respond to stress and part
of those experiments we're going to take
place here conch reef now mostly we're
going to take place in the lab which is
big shape lab experiments are valuable
but they can't come close to replicating
the complexity of real ocean ecosystems
in the last century we've invested far
more in looking up at space than down at
our underwater world Sylvia says that
now more than ever we need to understand
our oceans collected
nearly now that we know the fusion
climate and weather and shapes the way
that's where most of the water is for
most of Michaels we've been looking the
other way and
really upon us to recognize that
Aquarius is an amazing place as I head
back to the surface
I wonder what science will lose if this
facility closes silvia mark and many
others are trying to find a way to
restore funding for Aquarius but if that
doesn't happen it could be
decommissioned as early as December this
year for nature video I'm mark shrub